Hey everyone! Dr. Byrd here, and welcome to the third part of our series on elasticity. In this one, we are going to be calculating the price elasticity of demand. Let's go ahead and jump into seeing how we do that. Let's first recall that the elasticity of demand is the percentage change in quantity demand over the percentage change in price. And if we were to expand this what we would see it would be Q2 minus Q1. That is the ending value minus the starting value. Over the starting value quantity. And then we would do price 2 - price 1. The ending price and the starting price over the starting price. The issue with this is you do not get an accurate measurement between the two points. If I start at point A and I go to point B I'm going to get one number. If I go from point B and then back to point A I'm actually going to get a completely different elasticity of demand. So instead what we have to do is rely on what we called the midpoint method.
Alright. The midpoint method is actually going to take the average
of those two price and quantity points. So let's let this be Q1, P1 and Q2 and P2. And the midpoint formula--the midpoint method--comes in and says the elasticity of demand between these two points, points A and point B, lies right here. And it gives us an accurate measurement every single time when we are doing the midpoint method.
We are going to have an elasticity of demand formula that looks like this Q2 - Q1 over Q2 + Q1 and divide that by 2.
And then this is going to be over
P2 - P1 divided by P2 + P1 and you divide that by 2. So these are two separate expressions that we would have solved for and then we get our elasticity of demand. Now this is a very big scary formula. Luckily, we can get rid of this 2 and get rid of a lot of this division that is taking place by simplifying this formula down to look something like this: the elasticity of demand is equal to Q2 - Q1 over P2 - P1. And then we multiply that by P2 + P1 over Q2 + Q1. That makes it much easier to work with and it gives us the same result that we would use right here.
Let's jump into two examples just to see how we calculate the elasticity of demand using this midpoint formula. Let's start with a table that has prices and quantities associated with it and my numbers are going to be $50. $40 $30, $20,
$10 and $0.
And then my associated quantities are going to be 20, 40 and then we're going to have 60, 80, 100 and then 200
Let's pick 2 numbers to work with. Let's pick 30 and 20 as our two prices and that gives us 60 and 80 as our two quantities. So
at a price of 20 and that gives us a quantity of a 80. So P1 is going to be 20 and Q1 will be 80. We are going to increase our price from 20 to 30, and this will give us a price of 30 as our ending price and a quantity of 60 as our end quantity. Let's take these numbers and then plug them in.
This will give us
60 - 80  over
30 - 20. Multiply that by
60 + 80,
excuse me, we do price not quantity. Look at me messing up. We'll have 30 + 20 over 60 + 80. Alright, this simplifies down to -20/10 and the minus is there just to remind us that we are dealing with a downward-sloping demand curve and so price and quantity or inversely related.
And then we mulitply that result by 50 over 140. And this is going to simplify down to minus 2 times something right here. Times, I believe, it is 0.3571, yes I did that my head just now. And this is going to equal--
this is going to equal 0.71.
So our price elasticity of demand when going from $20 to $30 is 0.71. Since that is less than 1 it is inelastic. We have inelastic demand. A 1% increase in price causes a 0.71% decrease in quantity demand.
Let's look at one more example to conclude this. Let's look at a graph. We're going to have a
nice-looking graph here. Quantity and then price on the vertical axis. Our demand curve is downward-sloping. Let's put three different points in here.
We're going to have $9 correspond to a quantity of 20.
And then let's move right here and we're going to have $8 correspond to a quantity of 25.
And then our last one will have $7 correspond to a quantity of 30.
And let's say that we are going to go from point B, actually let's call this point A.
We're going to go from point A to point B. So we're traveling along our demand curve. Our price is decreasing by a dollar. Our quantity is increasing by 5. Let's plug this into our formula. So our second quantity is 25 our first is 20.
Over our second price of 8 minus our first price of 9. And then multiply that by eight plus nine--our two prices--over 25 + 20--our two quantities. And let's solve this down. This is going to give us 5 over -1 time 17 over 45--17 / 45.  When we multiply this, and 5 over -1 is just -5,
we are going to get - 5 * 17/45. And this is going to give us 1.89 as our elasticity of demand.
Since this is greater than 1,
this is greater than one, we are price elastic.
Alight, price elastic. That means a 1% increase in price will cause a 1.89% decrease in quantity demand so moving down this demand curve will give us a 1.89% decrease in our quantity demand. Or excuse me, if we're moving down it will give us a 1.89% increase in our quantity demand. Alright! That's it for calculating the price elasticity of demand. Hope you have enjoyed it and we will catch you turn off fourth installment.